[Music]
the clock is ticking but there is still
time to seal the deal before the united
nations climate summit wraps up today in
glasgow scotland
delegates from nearly 200 nations are
attempting to keep the goal of the 2015
paris climate accords alive
by limiting the threshold on rising
temperatures to 1.5 degrees celsius
that's just a couple degrees fahrenheit
the numbers may seem fractional but it's
part of the many hopes of this summit
which have struggled to become reality
mark phillips has the story
demonstrators have been allowed into the
conference center on what was supposed
to be its last day
perhaps as a way to concentrate the
delegates minds
there is still a large gap between what
these people think needs to be done to
keep global warming to a manageable
level united and what this conference
has apparently agreed to actually do how
could we possibly in 2021 knowing what
the evidence is
be wishy-washy on that subject as the
deadline approached delegates were still
arguing over significant sticking points
u.s climate envoy john kerry wanted to
include a limit on the unabated use of
coal
where the planet warming carbon dioxide
from this worst of fossil fuels is
vented into the atmosphere
others like china's zia zenua but also
india australia and others argued coal
was still needed for development and
could be phased out more slowly even the
u.s has not signed a total coal ban
there have been some specific limited
agreements here on stopping future
deforestation on reducing emissions of
methane a potent greenhouse gas
on phasing out coal in the long term
but the conference's main objective of
keeping global warming to 1.5 degrees
celsius as was agreed in the paris
climate accords is its most contentious
at this point all the promises made of
greenhouse gas cuts would still allow
the planet to warm almost three degrees
with all the catastrophic consequences
the conference failed to solve another
major problem as well money the world's
richer nations had promised to pay the
poorest and most vulnerable 100 billion
dollars a year by now to compensate for
the damage global warming was doing and
to help move them toward green
technologies
now that promise has been put off too
for two more years
and as you know we and small islands
have used the slogan 1.5 to stay alive
how disappointed are you
that the money that
countries like yours were promised
in paris is still
not been delivered
well we are very disappointed because
it's a promise
made a promise failed you want them to
show you the money
that too yes
a climate think tank in princeton new
jersey has produced a grim little movie
showing what science says will be the
result of three degrees of warming
contrasted with what would happen if
greenhouse gases are reduced
for instance south florida can't be
defended miami will be gone one day but
if that happens more slowly
fewer people will lose money fewer
people will lose livelihoods will be
able to manage it
so where do we stand now negotiators
have been up all night producing yet
another final draft for this conference
it still has to be approved
it does provide for more of a prospect
for more money for poorer countries and
about the end of the use of fossil fuels
particularly coal but does it get us to
that magic 1.5 degree celsius figure
beyond which global heating would become
critical
not yet
for cbs saturday morning i'm mark
phillips in glasgow
oh
mark always great to see mark by the way
so thank you for that yeah i mean and he
touched on this that one of the big
disputes here is that between rich and
poor nations and his poor nation's
saying you can afford to do this we
can't and also you've promised a certain
amount of money and haven't delivered it
right and i think people might think
well a few degrees what difference does
that make right but a scientist
explained to me when the body the human
body has a fever that's an indication
that the body is struggling that systems
are failing and same with the planet and
so um that really kind of put it into
perspective what's a great analogy yeah
got to get buy-in from everyone around
the world
thank you